let's continue talking about nspca and
how you can help them our friends at
findlay acura the sponsors of this
segment are telling us how they and you
can join a good cause jc shows us more
finley acura has a wide variety of
vehicles to choose from like the tlx
type s stylish and sporty how about this
the 2022 acura rdx they've got a huge
selection of pre-owned vehicles to
choose from but one of the best things
about finley acura is the variety of
charities that they help out let's go
inside and learn more
hey travis how's it going buddy going
great jc how are you my friend good to
see you merry christmas great to see you
merry christmas so you have a great
variety of cars outside but what i love
about you guys you're always helping out
a variety of charities who are you guys
working with this month this month we're
with the nevada spca
so we wanted to partner with them this
time of year of course there's always a
great need for adoptions as well as
fundraising so we wanted to highlight
everything that they have going on right
now and we have amy here today to talk a
little bit more about uh the details of
everything that they're doing in the
community perfect i love it man let's do
it amy how are you hi
it's so good to see you here good to see
you i'm so glad that you guys are
working together for for those that are
not familiar with the nevada spca why
don't you tell everybody what you guys
do absolutely so nevada spca is a
non-profit shelter we've been around
since 1983 and we're the original no
kill shelter in southern nevada really
we're a safety net for a lot of people
that aren't able to care for their
animals anymore and we want to be a
resource to those people so someone's
watching right now and they want to
adopt a pet how does the adoption
process work so easy so nevada's pc is
actually now open to walk-ins so if you
visit our website nevadaspc.org you can
just see all the animals that we have
available cats dogs and small pets and
you're able to come into our shelter
directly and meet with them and and so
like so like myself i've got two dogs
and two horses but if if we're
interested in getting another pet
another cat another dog can i bring my
two dogs down to see if they can if the
puppies and cats get along with each
other always recommend that i think it's
the best for that animal to meet so that
we kind of make sure that they're the
right fit that there's no issues and we
will always tell you we'll guide you in
that process to make sure that hey this
animal is friendly with other dogs no
problem or hey you know maybe not this
particular dog maybe we'll look at
another animal for you and this time of
year i think a lot of people want to
volunteer and give back in in las vegas
is such a pet lover's town how can
people help you guys absolutely so our
volunteer program is going to kick back
up in the new year so we're not ready uh
yet but donations are critical you know
we're supported entirely by the
community so donations like blankets and
towels are things that we always use but
we have an amazon wishlist a chewy wish
list on our website we'd love for people
to see that um and come help us because
we have so many animals that need that
well thank you so much amy of course a
pup a pet makes a great addition to your
family and so does travis a new car
pre-owned vehicle before we go do you
guys have any specials we do we actually
have not only new car specials we have
pre-owned vehicle specials right now as
well we also have access to southern
nevada's largest pre-owned inventory
with full access to the findlay auto
group's pre-owned inventory so we really
are a one-stop shop even if you're
looking for some extra christmas cash we
can purchase your vehicle get you a
great cash offer as well awesome thank
you travis appreciate it buddy thank you
jc thank you amy
thank you findlay acura for sponsoring
this segment they're located at 315 auto
mall drive in henderson for more
information call
702-982-4100 or visit finley